twelve-year-old Yasin and his dad are on
their way to football practice passing
torched cars the result of last week's
violence
and a mural of French Striker kylian
mbappe
the national hero learned to play
football in this working-class
neighborhood just north of Paris
it gives them hope to see that someone
who grew up here in the same conditions
is as successful as they can be it's a
very important message that he had it
can appease them because for them he is
an example
[Applause]
when riots began a week ago following
the death of 17 year old Niel after
being shot by police mbappe's voice
managed what others could not the French
Striker released a statement as many of
us come from working class neighborhoods
he says we also share these feelings of
pain and sadness but violence as he goes
on is self-destruction
words rang true and louder than any
ministers or Mayors
there is words have been a factor which
played an important role he both paid
tribute to Nile and expressed his desire
for the situation to cool down
as France begins rebuilding after the
estimated billion dollars of damage
caused by the riots figures like mbappe
want people here to be given the chance
of a better future but one where
violence is not the answer Dimitri
medvedenko Al Jazeera